of all the big practically as we've
heard there is one that has so far gone
unchallenged the notion that Britain now
exports far more outside the EU than
inside but what if this isn't quite
right either to get things straight I've
travel tune of garden it might be five
thousand miles from London but there is
one important thing that links Britain
and this part of the u.s. gold if we
look closely enough the answer about
what's really going on with the UK's
trade figures might be found here
somewhere under the ground this is the
cortes gold mine the biggest in North
America they've been digging in the
ground here since the California Gold
Rush
but things have moved on a bit since
then this is mining on a scale you can
barely imagine
look closely at this digger you can see
it's higher than a three-story house you
could easily fit a minibus inside that
bucket between them those trucks shift
rocks and earth weighing more than the
Empire State Building every single day
and that's just the open pit mine they
also dig down deep inside the earth and
that's where my journey took me next
even here is not quite how you'd
envisage it no elevator shaft or gold
seams instead fast tunnels big enough to
drive through you're not gonna see
pickaxes and we don't have the dwarves
down here
yes you know the smallest heading we
have here is 15 foot by 15 foot fairly
large equipment you know we're running
30 tonne truck about 2,000 feet beneath
ground level at the moment it's pretty
hot bit sticky this is where it will
begin for this this gets drilled it gets
sent to the surface and turn from what
looks like rock into that precious metal
we all recognize that's only the start
of a journey that takes it all around
the world after the digging the crushing
the grinding in these enormous mills the
wincing in cyanide solution you heat the
product up beyond a thousand degrees and
this is what you get
molten gold this is what all that work
was about the ultimate precious metal
but actually that's only the start of
our story once these gold bars are
finished here cooled down and cleaned up
they're flown usually on a passenger
flight over to Switzerland there they
refined even further to get the purity
up and then their transfer to London why
because it turns out Britain is the
world capital for the trade of physical
gold if you think about Heathrow is a
major terminal airport terminal people
can come get a flight from one place
change flights go somewhere else
London is known as a terminal market for
physical bullion it's where gold comes
to rest have a cup of coffee maybe
before it then moves on somewhere else
go somewhere else in the world so as we
follow the journey of our gold bars this
is where they'll end up next hidden
somewhere inside the m25 I'm inside one
of those high security installations now
so high security I can't tell you
precisely where we are but here is the
finished article these are London good
delivery gold bars they are small but
surprisingly heavy and between the two
of them they're worth the best part of a
million pounds and that's really the nub
of this story a few of these are enough
to distort Britain's trade figures
completely changing our perception of
the UK's relationship with Europe and
the rest of the world
and here's why most of the gold that
gets sold in London then gets flown off
around the world some of it to China
Suffolk to India some back to
Switzerland to be melted into smaller
bars and then sent again what are those
countries have in common they're all
outside the EU so this constant flow of
gold in and out of London makes it look
as if Britain is doing far more trade
outside Europe than it actually is
Sky News analysis reveals the scale that
Distortion
the official trade figures showed that
in the past five years only 46 percent
of Britain's goods exports went to the
EU but strip out gold and it's a
different story Britain actually
exported fully half of its physical
goods to Europe in other words perhaps
we're not quite the great trading nation
we may think we are food for thought as
we consider the post brexit world much
of unders gold is to be found here in
the vaults underneath the Bank of
England we asked to have a look inside
but again due to security reasons they
only open their doors to dignitaries
like Queen the window is that Britain
doesn't own most of this gold it doesn't
mine it will produce it and yet when it
leaves the country it looks on the
surface like a UK export that's because
Britain is the world leader in looking
after other people's gold
but might not roll be in doubt - this is
bad
the last refinery left in the capital
it's a smallish operation melting down
scrap metal into gold bars which it
mostly sells to Asian investors it's
boss suspects London's preeminence as
the world's gold hub may be under threat
but the market but like all sort of
global commodity markets are shifting
eastwards
the police do see to extent attacks well
under market from the EU or from the US
all it appears to do so far is drive the
business to Asia it's the same worry as
the one facing the city will brexit
undermine Britain's reputation for being
a good place to bring your money or
store your gold
the great irony is that the vast
majority of the gold being pulled out of
the ground back here in America will end
its life under the ground somewhere else
in the world but as long as it comes via
London it will continue to confuse the
picture of how much trade we do with the
rest of the world at Conway Sky News in
Nevada